un poète sans lunettes c'est le visage
d'aimé césaire telle qu'on ne l'a jamais
vu en public de son vivant les voleurs
ont ils voulu voir ce qu'il y avait
derrière la monture en pierre on ignore
pour l'instant leur motivation ni
combien il était pour la découpe et et
l'emporter césar et sa lunette c'est une
histoire qui remonte à très loin
elles font partie du personnage d'abord
parce qu'il a des problèmes de vue ce
n'est donc pas une coquetterie
ensuite parce qu'il est timide et que ça
l'aide à se cacher d'une façon ou d'une
autre dans les années 30 c'est à porte
déjà des lunettes quand ils enfantent la
négritude avec senghor et damas dans les
années 2000 elles sont plus
indispensables encore à la mort de
camille darsières cl tellement choqué
qu'il fait une poussée de tension
oculaire qui l'empêchent de lire livres
et journaux comme avant c'est elle et
ses lunettes pour sa dernière père et
fait venir son opticien dans son bureau
à l'ancienne mairie de fort-de-france
il peut alors faire son choix parmi
plusieurs montures les lunettes retenu
ce jour là ont depuis sa mort en 2008
été reproduite sur tous les buts qui lui
rendent hommage
le vol du diamant survient un mois après
le succès des journées du patrimoine le
public s'étaient pressés pour visiter la
maison du poète et découvrir l'intimité
de son génie si les voleurs du diamant
cherche elle aussi à mieux connaître
l'oeuvre de césaire et bien ils ont
chaussé les mauvaises lunettes en
confondant les verts d'une monture avec
les vers d'un poème